when we go into the wilderness for a
vision we don't leave behind us the
intellectual accomplishments of our
civilization i mean husserl and
wittgenstein and freud all these people
go with us and are weighed and
considered in the light of the vision
when it finally comes so that what's
happening is that shamanism is being
practiced in a new ontological
environment the environment as you said
of post-modernism and
post-heidiger and post-whitehead and
these having this kind of a cultural
momentum behind us gives us an entirely
new slant
on on shamanic phenomena essentially
science is a is a fallen shamanism you
know a and a
it's almost the brujo
brand of shamanism but if it could be
brought back into line with the notion
of
contemplation and
and
resonance rather than interference with
nature and some of these other
principles i mean i think science can be
transformed the first step is to humble
it because it it now is
you know the handmaiden of the imperium
and giving therefore a very false moral
picture of reality if nothing else
so
yes i think shamanism is evolving and
that there is not now being practiced a
finished shamanism on the planet and
that it's the richness of our cultural
heritage that will
allow us and to create new avenues tour
into it to understand it
i guess i guess what i'm getting at is
that it seems that we live at least both
of us who live in cities
live primarily in an information
environment particularly an electronic
information environment
as opposed to an organic or biological
environment
and that when you
when you go to a place like joshua tree
then you are allowing yourself to return
to
a form of
a kind of nature mysticism
right or proto-shamanism that is
embedded in a matrix of energies
which most people
no longer have contact with
yes well this may be an argument
actually for this earlier notion that i
put forth about communities far from
the clash of
the cities where famine and politics is
being practiced there is something to it
i mean i wouldn't want to say that it's
impossible to conduct a program of
spiritual growth while living in a city
that isn't it but on the other hand you
know we do
have very little experience with the
impact of living in the multiple
radiation shell that a modern city
represents i mean your body is being
bombarded with
uhf vhf
all kinds of
weird stuff and chemicals and human
pheromones and industrial
output and all of these things there's
something to be said for
cleansing in the wilderness and then
inevitably most people have to return to
the city this is this is what i saw
on this recent excursion was the
intensity with which people gather
vision and i mean people who were
you know held very urban type positions
computer programmers designers public
relations people would strip themselves
naked and offer themselves to the
elements and journey a hundred thousand
years back into time and battle monsters
and you just had to say you know
people
are doing it they are taking the
intrusion of the archaic into modernity
with great seriousness the the thing
which was originally only an intimation
is becoming uh a thread now in the great
weave of uh what is going on and it
seems that eventually perhaps it will
influence the whole pattern the renewal
nature is the source of renewal because
nature represents an order outside of
the order created by the accumulated
historical mistakes
well uh
the reason i raised this question
one of the reasons i guess is because it
seems that your work
seems to your work points to
a kind of gnostic transcendence of
what you call the monkey body and the
terrestrial
world
you lay great emphasis on
on i guess if you put it becoming
creatures of pure imagination so that
leaves one with the question of what
what relevance you felt the natural
world had
to any kind of
um
you know teleological human evolution it
seems as though you were kind of leaving
it behind you're leaving the physical
body behind
and leaving the physical world behind as
um
elements
inhibitory elements that needed to be
discarded in order for human
consciousness to evolve into its final
form uh final state
well i appreciate such a close reading
of what i've said yes there is this
question about
what i think of nature what i think of
nature is not that it is something to be
overcome
or transcended it isn't nature which has
put us in this problem it's history that
i am concerned to
break out of and i think that the
understanding of natural process
is probably one of the ways to do this
that eventually we will do everything
the way nature does all machines will be
made by dna
all
production of objects will be through
molecular transcription of information
but that you know we are evolving as you
say beyond the monkey we are evolving
off planet what we will take with us
from nature is the understanding of
ourselves we are becoming almost our own
nature but what is really bringing us
down
is the historical uh
freight that we're carrying and that's
what i'm interested to get beyond
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you